community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
southwest medical the sponsors of this
next segment they're giving back to our
community in celebration of a very
special milestone i spoke with them and
helping hands of vegas valley about what
they're up to together
you have a special story you want to
share with the community right i i would
um
you know it actually starts back in the
year 1972 with a
cardiologist named anthony marlin coming
to the valley and opening up his
practice and
he actually decided to
expand his practice into a
multi-specialty group and in the early
1980s
uh
he established the first federally
qualified health maintenance
organization in southern nevada that we
all know is health plan of of nevada
and um over the next four decades uh uh
he named his multi-specialty group
southwest medical associates and over
the next four decades southwest medical
associates has grown up with the
community uh and now represents uh the
largest multi-specialty group in las
vegas with over
450 uh providers
so um
really especially proud uh
to make a note of the fact that this is
our 50th year anniversary uh for
southwest medical and serving this
community and you know this is a
homegrown medical practice and you know
a thing or two about that as well right
i do the the macbeth family came to the
valley in the 1940s
and i actually
grew up here and
was educated in the state of nevada and
was really
fortunate to be able to come back to
this community after residency training
and practice
a medicine which i did for you know more
than 25 years and
always strive to be that
trusted partner providing high quality
care i was taking care of many of my
lifelong friends and their parents and
families and and so it was a very
important and special place uh for me
now marcia let's bring you up here and
and tell us more about helping hands of
vegas valley and what it means to you
and what you guys do for us
so helping hands in vegas valley has
been off in the valley for 21 years so
like southwest medical we are homegrown
we do have four focus areas so we have a
respite care voucher program for
families who are full-time caregivers of
loved ones to be able to take a break we
have a minor home repair program where
we go into seniors homes to help make
sure they're living safely
then we have our transportation program
where we have
six vehicles and six professional
drivers that transport our clients to
medical appointments and then
we have a food pantry program where we
have a walk-in pantry home delivered
groceries home delivered meals and then
a
rural program where we deliver meals to
the world communities how can we lend a
helping hand to helping hands if you go
to our website there's places where you
can sign up to volunteer and then as
always we love donations so
cash donations in-kind donations we have
people that do food drives or blanket
drives all the ways you can get involved
are on our website
thank you again to southwest medical for
being a community pride partner and
happy 50th